Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Lampes, sacs en plastique, stylos, brosses à dents,
jouets, récipients, ventilateurs...
Tous ces objets ont un point commun :
ils sont en plastique, partiellement ou totalement.
Légère et pas chère,
cette matière est omniprésente dans notre quotidien
et en particulier dans les emballages.
Même l'écran dans lequel vous me regardez
contient du plastique.
Dans les années 80,
le groupe "Elmer Food Beat" chantait "Le plastique, c'est fantastique."
Ce matériau constitue une source de pollution importante.
Chaque année, plus de 8 millions
de tonnes de plastique
finissent dans les mers et les océans.
Alors, un monde sans plastique est-il possible ?
On va répondre à cette question avec quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
et qui s'exprime souvent sur ce genre de sujet,
Chris, de la chaîne Poisson Fécond.
Salut, Jamy !
Bon, pas la peine de faire de grands discours.
En France,
on est clairement accro au plastique
et chaque année, nous utilisons 5 millions de tonnes de plastique.
Ça représente quasiment 70 kilos par habitant
et les emballages ménagers, à eux seuls, en représentent un quart.
Mais le problème, c'est que les plastiques
mettent des centaines d'années à se décomposer.
Par exemple, 20 ans pour un sac plastique ou 450 ans pour une bouteille en PET.
Et du coup, le plastique, c'est loin d'être fantastique.
L'autre problème,
c'est que l'on retrouve le plastique dans les mers et dans les océans.
Vous avez sûrement déjà entendu parler
du "Vortex de déchets" du Pacifique Nord.
Des milliards de particules de plastique se retrouvent en suspension
et forment ce que l'on appelle, aussi, le septième continent.
Sa taille est estimée à 1,6 million de kilomètres carrés,
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
ça représente quasiment 3 fois la taille de la France métropolitaine.
Mais du coup, comment en est-on arrivé là ?
On commence à produire du plastique, de manière industrielle,
après la Première Guerre mondiale.
C'est ainsi qu'apparaissent les premiers caoutchoucs synthétiques,
le nylon, les poignées de casseroles isolantes...
L'industrie chimique est alors en pleine expansion et les gisements de pétrole
et de gaz, avec lesquels on produit le plastique, se multiplient.
Le grand boom a lieu dans les années 50
avec l'avènement de la société de consommation.
À cette époque, la production mondiale de plastique
est à peu près de 2 millions de tonnes par an,
c'est très peu comparé à aujourd'hui.
On est aux alentours de 400 millions de tonnes.
Alors, les raisons de son succès sont multiples,
notamment pour les emballages.
C'est un matériau stérile, les bactéries ne se développent pas dessus,
idéal donc pour conserver les aliments.
Il est léger, résistant et pas cher, donc accessible
et puis on peut en faire ce que l'on veut.
Il est aussi facilement transportable.
Tenez, par exemple, les bouteilles autrefois en verre laissent place
aux bouteilles en plastique, plus légère et moins fragile.
Rapidement, donc, il est vu comme la solution.
Revers de la médaille, les plastiques produisent
des déchets qui, jetés dans la nature,
peuvent mettre des centaines d'années à se désintégrer.
Ce qui engendre de graves problèmes de pollution,
avec des conséquences désastreuses sur la faune et la flore.
Et ce n'est pas tout,
le plastique est fabriqué à partir de pétrole, une énergie fossile
qui n'est pas renouvelable
et dont les réserves diminuent inexorablement.
Sans compter que la destruction du plastique par combustion
émet de grandes quantités de CO2,
l'un des principaux gaz à effet de serre
responsable du réchauffement climatique.
Il faut donc en utiliser le moins possible et le recycler.
D'un point de vue énergétique,
son recyclage permet de faire des économies de pétrole conséquentes.
Pour vous donner une idée, recycler une tonne de bouteilles
permet d'économiser 830 litres de pétrole.
Avec une bouteille en PET, on peut refaire la même bouteille en PET,
en sachant que ces bouteilles contiennent en moyenne
25% de PET recyclé et ça peut aller jusqu'à 100%.
Le problème, c'est que malheureusement,
100% des plastiques
ne sont pas recyclables.
Pour rentrer dans les détails, les plastiques qui peuvent se recycler
sont déjà les polyéthylènes téréphtalates.
À vos souhaits.
Les polyéthylènes haute densité, dont vous savez,
les fameux PET, PE-HD associés à des numéros de 1 à 6.
Pour faire plus simple, on parle ici de bouteille d'eau,
de gel douche ou même de liquide
vaisselle.
Bref, tout cela est bel et bien recyclable, et voici comment ça se passe.
La première étape, elle se passe chez vous.
Oui, parce que c'est votre bac de tri qui permet de lancer le processus.
Une fois collecté puis séparé par matériaux,
les cartons d'un côté, l'aluminium de l'autre,
les différents emballages plastiques arrivent dans une autre usine.
Pour les bouteilles, par exemple, elles sont broyées en paillettes
puis lavées pour retirer les étiquettes.
Et, c'est grâce à ces fameuses paillettes
que le plastique va pouvoir être réutilisé pour fabriquer de nouveaux objets.
Avec le PET, on fabrique aussi des emballages alimentaires.
On le recycle en bouteilles, en flacons ou en barquettes.
Et, ça sert aussi à fabriquer des fibres pour le textile.
Il faut en moyenne 6 flacons de liquide vaisselle pour
rembourrer un ours en peluche
et 27 bouteilles pour confectionner un pull.
Enfin, avec les autres types de plastiques, on fait des arrosoirs,
des sacs poubelles, des pare-chocs, des bacs à compost...
Mais l'objectif aujourd'hui, pour les plastiques alimentaires,
c'est le principe de la boucle fermée.
Pour faire simple,
qu'une bouteille en plastique redevienne une bouteille en plastique après recyclage.
C'est déjà le cas et ça le sera aussi en 2025 pour nos pots de yaourt ou
même nos barquettes de jambon.
Vous le voyez, certains plastiques peuvent être recyclés,
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tous.
Du coup, depuis 2021, de nombreux produits de la vie
courante, en plastique, ne sont plus commercialisés en France.
C'est le cas des couverts, des pailles, des gobelets,
des coton-tiges et de nombreux contenants alimentaires.
Et, vous ne devinerez jamais, avec quoi
on conçoit maintenant certains de ces emballages !
Avec du papier carton.
Il est renouvelable, facilement recyclable
sauf qu'il a, lui aussi, ses limites.
Il est perméable à l'eau et aux matières grasses,
un handicap quand on souhaite emballer des aliments.
Il ne peut pas non plus supporter des charges lourdes.
Du coup, pour l'utiliser à la place du plastique,
il faut le renforcer avec un film en aluminium ou bien
un film en plastique, ce qui complexifie le recyclage.
Au fait, il y a un autre matériau dont on n'a pas trop parlé
et qui présente des avantages sur le plastique
et c'est le verre.
Il représente, à lui seul, 50% du poids de tous les emballages ménagers.
C'est aussi le champion du taux de recyclage en France : 88%.
Par contre, il y a aussi quelques inconvénients.
Son recyclage est très énergivore,
pour recycler le verre, il faut faire chauffer la matière jusqu'à 1 000 degrés,
ce qui va alors générer 350 grammes de CO2 par bouteille.
De plus, le transport du verre requiert de le protéger avec
de l'emballage supplémentaire pour éviter la casse.
Et, comme c'est un matériau lourd, il oblige à consommer plus de carburant.
En revanche, un objet en verre peut être réutilisé,
c'est le principe de la consigne, par exemple.
On rapporte au commerçant le flacon vide
et en échange, celui-ci nous donne une petite somme d'argent.
Cette démarche a déjà fait ses preuves dans le passé,
elle revient en force aujourd'hui.
Et pas seulement pour les boissons,
on trouve aussi des petits pots pour bébé
dans les emballages consignés.
Et sinon, pourquoi pas faire sans emballage ?
Eh bien , justement, c'est le principe du vrac,
les produits sont vendus sans être emballés,
le client se déplace avec son propre contenant.
Cependant, aujourd'hui, il n'existe pas d'alternative "vrac"
à tous les emballages en plastique.
Pour certains produits frais ou liquides notamment,
ça reste quand même la meilleure option.
On a encore besoin du plastique pour faire des emballages de médicaments,
pour certains produits d'hygiène, de shampoings, de savons liquides.
Toutefois, dans ce cas précis,
on a toujours la possibilité
d'optimiser les emballages
pour réduire drastiquement la quantité de plastique utilisée.
Et là, il suffirait de diminuer l'épaisseur des emballages
ou de réduire les espaces vides.
Pour demain, certains rêvent même d'un monde sans plastique
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment possible ?
Malheureusement, on en est encore loin.
D'après un rapport de l'OCDE, en 2060,
les êtres humains produiront et utiliseront 3 fois plus de plastique qu'aujourd'hui.
Nous consommerons, alors,
plus de 1 200 millions de tonnes de plastique chaque année.
Sur une population estimée à 10 milliards d'habitants,
c'est l'équivalent de 65 sacs en plastique, neuf par jour
et par habitant ;
d'où l'importance du recyclage.
Mais pour qu'il soit efficace, il faut commencer par limiter
notre consommation de plastique
et respecter les règles de tri
afin d'éviter qu'ils finissent dans la nature.
D'ailleurs, Jamy, tu le sais
sans doute,
plusieurs initiatives s'attaquent déjà à ce problème.
Entre "Ocean Cleanup", "Plastic Odyssey", "Ma rivière sans plastique",
il existe une multitude de projets
ayant pour objectif
de nettoyer les rivières et les océans.
Leur but ?
Capter les déchets et les plastiques présents dans les eaux,
à la sortie des égouts et avant même qu'ils arrivent dans la mer.
Et dans le genre, les "clean walks" sont très efficaces, aussi.
En fait, ce sont des citoyens qui se regroupent pour collecter
manuellement les déchets qui traînent un peu partout
sur les plages, dans les rues, dans les parcs.
Bref, vous le voyez, ça bouge.
Et, de leur côté, les pouvoirs publics ne sont pas non plus en reste,
avec les lois environnementales
de plus en plus strictes ou la mise en place de taxes plus ou moins lourdes
en fonction de l'impact des emballages utilisés.
Là, c'est le principe de pollueur, payeur.
Et quand à nous, les consommateurs,
nous avons aussi le pouvoir de faire avancer les choses.
En fait, il y a plein de possibilités, rappelez-vous,
le meilleur déchet, c'est celui qu'on ne produit pas.
Choisir les produits avec le moins d'emballages possible,
voire préférer le vrac ou encore participer aux clean walks.
N'hésitez pas à adopter des gestes éco-citoyens : si vous croisez
un emballage plastique qui traîne par terre, jetez-le au bon endroit, le bac de tri.
Merci Chris, pour cet échange.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à liker et vous abonner,
si ce n'est pas encore fait.
À revisionner aussi car il y avait beaucoup d'infos,
ce n'est pas de l'usage unique.
Enfin, si vous avez des idées de sujets, partagez-les en commentaire,
elles seront étudiées avec soin.
Allez, à très bientôt.
Excellente fin de journée,
bonne semaine et à dimanche prochain pour une nouvelle vidéo épicurieuse.